RYAN MATSUMOTO: Today,
we're talking about updates
to infrastructure,
Memorystore, Looker,
and contextual tutorials.
I'm Ryan, and welcome
to This Week in Cloud,
where we serve you the
lowest latency news.
In the span of
just three months,
Google Cloud teams
delivered a ton
of new and innovative
capabilities
for compute, networking,
storage, serverless,
and containers.
From Transfer Appliance
to Tau VMs to scaling,
check out the summary to see
what you may have missed.
Maintenance is critical,
but related downtimes
can be costly.
We're excited to announce
that Cloud Memorystore now
enables you to have more
control over when your Cloud
Memorystore for Redis instances
undergo routine maintenance.
This control comes in the form
of rescheduling and advance
notification capabilities,
which will be familiar controls
for Cloud SQL users.
Head to the blog to learn more.
The Extension Framework is
a fully hosted development
platform that enables
developers to build
any data-powered
application, workflow,
or tool right in Looker.
By eliminating the need to spin
up and host infrastructure,
the Extension Framework
lets developers
focus on building great
experiences for their users.
Do you know that
there's a way to learn
how to use Google Cloud
products built right
into the Google Cloud console?
In-console tutorials can walk
you through complete actions
without having to open another
window for documentation.
Features like spotlights,
buttons, and code snippets
make getting your project up
and running easier than ever.
They'll pop up automatically,
but to check out
our list of existing
Firestore tutorials,
head to the linked blog.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Any thoughts or ideas?
Leave us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the Cloud.